Oh Man.
Hor One giant special effects budget.
Can you believe that after 50 years,
conspiracy theories about the
moon landing are still in orbit?
Roughly 6% of Americans believe the moon
landing was faked while another 5% are
undecided. What do you think it
would take to pull off such a hoax?
How many people would have to keep
quiet and how much would it cost?
This is what if,
and here's what would need to happen
to fake the moon landing lights,
camera action.
July 16th,
1969 exterior launchpad, Neil Armstrong,
Buzz Aldrin, and Michael Collins Board,
the Apollo 11 spacecraft bound
for the moon across the world.
600 million people watch live as the
three men are launched into space.
Land safely on the moon, plant the stars
and Stripes and make it home safely.
Come to think of it.
That does sound a lot like Hollywood,
but can you think of a studio with
a $150 billion operating budget?
In total, the Apollo program was
allocated $24 billion to get to the moon.
Roughly 60% of NASA's budget at the time.
That equals 150 billion
in today's dollars.
Assuming all that money went into
pulling off the perfect hoax,
how would they have spent it? Let's
start with payroll. At the time,
NASA had about 411,000
employees and Oxford physicist,
Dr. David Grimes,
calculated that the secret might have
had a chance to stay quiet for as long as
three years and eight months
with that many people.
So how do you keep 411,000 employees quiet
about a fake moon landing mission for
longer than three years?
A bribe might be able to buy some silence.
Today's NASA employees earn an average
of $62,500 if you divide the Apollo
budget in today's dollars amongst
a workforce of 411,000 people,
it comes to a payout of
roughly 365,000 per person.
Of course,
employees would have had to accept much
less given the cost of the equipment and
the production needed
to fake a moon landing.
You may have noticed that the shadows
in the photographs of the moon landing
appear to be parallel image forensics.
Say these shadows accurately reflect
the sun's position from 93 million miles
away. Under conventional studio lighting,
the shadows would appear more divergent,
meaning NASA would have to step up their
game in order to achieve a convincing
look to properly fake the sun's lighting
in the 1960s would require a wall of
millions of powerful laser
lights so close together.
They'd be like pixels
on a computer screen.
Now consider that the 150
billion committed to the
Apollo program was spent on
six separate visits to the moon, so
whatever the cost of the first conspiracy,
bribes equipment, et Cetera,
multiply that by six.
In 2009 NASA's lunar reconnaissance
orbiter sent back high resolution
photographs of each of the Apollo
Moon landing sites showing boot marks,
left astronauts to fake these NASA would
have had to send something to the moon,
like a robotic rover to make some tracks.
The combined cost of the vehicle and the
mission to put it on the moon would be
roughly $68 million.
Then another 504 million for a
lunar orbiter to take the pictures.
The bottom line of this prolonged spending
spree is that the cost of faking the
moon landing far outweighs the
cost of doing it for real. Luckily,
we are a species that puts
its money where its mouth is,
especially when we get curious.
And how's your appetite for adventure?
Are you ready for another one?